una larga fila en la estación londinense
de Saint Pancras hasta el viernes a
última hora esos viajeros lo intentaron
todo para comprar billetes de Eurostars
para dirigirse a Francia unos atascos
que también se presentaron en el puerto
Dover desde dónde salen los ferrys que
cruzan el Canal de la Mancha miles de
británicos querían adelantarse a la
entrada en vigor de las restricciones de
viaje impuestas por el gobierno francés
con la misma prisa en las personas que
desean viajar a Reino Unido desde París
se dirigen a la
las nuevas restricciones son una
respuesta al aumento de casos por la
variante Omicron en el Reino Unido el
viernes se registraron más de 90000
casos nuevos en 24 horas las nuevas
medidas también han provocado miles de
cancelaciones de los visitantes
británicos en Francia en las estaciones
de esquí francesas un frente hicimos una
noche de pruebas de antígeno para los
británicos que tuvieron que volver a
casa ahora las restricciones están en
vigor no podemos hacer otra temporada
tenemos que pagar los turistas
británicos representan el 15% de la
industria del esquí en Francia y se
espera que las cancelaciones masivas
tengan un gran impacto en toda la
industria